[Musique]
Vy P avec comme avait-il une grande
spécialiste des ressources humaines
Cernoy bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
présidente d'une société qui s'appelle
RH humaniste qui a son siège à
Versailles RH voilà relation humaine
humaniste pourquoi avoir choisi ce nom
humaniste
parce que c'est avant tout l'humain pour
moi c'est important en fait l'humain est
un élément clé pour la réussite de
l'entreprise absolument voilà il y a pas
de lessive il y a pas que les bénéfices
pour moi
il fait partie de toute la chaîne il
intervient à tous les niveaux et c'est
ce qui permet de la réussite non
seulement du riz dirigeant et de surtout
du projet de l'entreprise aussi alors on
va parler justement des nouvelles
problématiques dans l'entreprise de ces
ressources humaines de comment gérer
comment trouver des nouveaux managers
qu'est-ce qui change justement dans la
gestion des ressources humaines mais un
mot d'abord sur vous vous êtes vous avez
fait les secs
vous avez d'abord une carrière de DRH
quoi
en fait j'ai démarré d'un petit
structure où j'étais j'avais vraiment
les mains entre guillemets dans le
cambouis j'étais assistante de direction
et j'ai évolué on va dire au fil au fil
de l'eau et donc j'ai repris donc les
cours et donc j'ai effectivement obtenu
un Master RH à l'ESSEC qui a vraiment
boosté ma carrière donc j'ai occupé
ensuite donc des postes de direction RH
dans des PME environnement international
j'ai effectivement donc géré des
effectifs un périmètre entre 250 et 500
personnes voire 1200 et souvent c'était
le point commun c'est vraiment la mise
en place d'une politique RH mais
également le suivi opérationnel des
équipes et c'est ce qui me plaisait
voilà
la gestion quotidienne au fond des des
salariés et puis de leur devenir aussi
hein
leur quotidien salarié mais aussi le
quotidien des managers et du dirigeant
les différents
expertise évidemment en droit social et
en compétences techniques attendues au
métier ça c'est pour moi incontournable
parfois pas mal d'erreurs
non ça peut arriver
et ensuite évidemment donc les
compétences métiers incontournables et
avant tout ces fameuses soft skills
qu'on appelle donc les savoir-être qui
pour moi sont primordiales tout poste et
de DRH ou le savoir-être du DRH et de
comportement
savoir-être du DRH mais aussi également
de tout toute personne qui travaille en
entreprise et c'est pour moi c'est ce
qui c'est qui est le plus important donc
par exemple un
pour moi c'est la bienveillance c'est le
l'écoute l'écoute active
c'est également la bienveillance
tout le temps et choisis toujours le
tour le matin dans les bureaux avant de
reprendre mon ouais c'était pour moi
important c'est
un peu ce qui était appartient la
direction des entreprises mais qui est
peut-être peut-être un lien plus simple
aussi avec les salariés que les les
autres personnalités des cadres
dirigeants d'une entreprise peut-être
plus proche
et non oui et non je vous dirais parce
qu'il faut toujours garder oui voilà
mais en même temps faut toujours garder
cette ligne directrice
mais tout en étant orienté pour moi
c'est d'être orienté service client
interne
alors vous avez créé en 2017 RH le
ministres donc qui est à Versailles pas
loin du théâtre
vous vous adressez alors vous avez un
principe c'est de dire au TPE PME qui
n'ont pas forcément
l'idée de de
d'y avoir recours que c'est bien d'avoir
un conseiller extérieur en
ressources humaines
et de proposer effectivement des RH
enfin un service RH au TPE PME qui sont
pas forcément dotés de services RH en
interne ce qui permet aux dirigeants de
se concentrer sur son cœur de métier et
de se libérer de des tâches dites
chronophages dites par exemple
l'administratif
il est surtout les fronts et nous en
fait on vient justement le soulager de
ces tâches ressources humaines par
exemple avec l'offre que l'on lance en
ce moment qui s'appelle donc la haute
sourcing oxygénérache et qui propose
donc une un espace partagé aux
dirigeants et ils auront donc
effectivement accès à un consultant RH
dédié pour donc réaliser leur traitement
administratif RH mais également ils ont
accès à une communauté donc entre père
et donc des fiches pratiques RH de la
veille sociale mensuelle et aussi un
accès voilà puis aussi peut-être la
tentation parfois dans des petits
entreprises je dis ah bah ça servait
après ça vient pas après il faut ça
vient en même temps que le reste les
ressources humaines
le premier salarié par exemple vous avez
des obligations que le l'employeur ne
doit respecter c'est l'affichage
obligatoire c'est les formations
obligatoires dia salariés par exemple on
doit mettre en place le du
ERP qui est le document unique
d'évaluation des risques professionnels
sous peine badamonde si effectivement
demain il y a un contrôle
malheureusement voilà il y aura sanction
donc en fait on est là vraiment pour
veiller au respect de la réglementation
et d'aider l'eau de la loi du Code du
travail mais également on est là
effectivement pour mettre de l'huile
dans les rouages entre le salarié et le
manager ou le dirigeant c'est à dire de
rapporter encore une fois ce service
client interne et
un premier temps de votre activité c'est
le conseiller RH au TP au PME et puis
pour toutes les entreprises vous
travaillez aussi sur le recrutement et
la formation des managers en fait toutes
nos offres sont vraiment entendu sur
mesure quand je baisse du sur-mesure
c'est à dire qu'on est vraiment à
l'écoute des besoins du client
moi ce que j'aime c'est d'aller par
exemple donc chez l'entre dans
l'entreprise cliente et de d'écouter le
dirigeant son métier parce que c'est
important de bien comprendre le métier
que le client enfin que l'entreprise
effectivement donc et heureusement
exerce c'est aussi d'écouter ses besoins
en ressources humaines et d'adapter donc
l'offre par rapport à son besoin
par exemple on recrutement donc on fait
vraiment du recrutement sur mesure et on
va mettre en place par exemple une
stratégie de sourcing bien en phase avec
ce dont il a vraiment besoin et aussi
par rapport aux attentes du marché
comment on trouve le salarié idoine
des contacts des sources des
on peut il y a différents canaux en
termes de sourcing on fait souvent appel
évidemment donc aux annonces dans les
opportes classiques vous pouvez aussi
faire appel donc au cVTech donc elle est
effectivement chercher des candidats qui
sont enregistrés sur des bases de CV
mais également aussi vous avez de la
chasse qui sont réalisés par exemple sur
les réseaux sociaux donc là c'est ce
qu'on fait aussi donc voilà donc on fait
vraiment tout de A à Z jusqu'à
l'accompagnement du salarié en période
d'essai c'est à dire qu'on pense oui on
présente on va donc suivre le manager ce
qui recrute et le salarié pendant sa
période d'essai parce que pour moi un
recrutement réussi effectivement c'est
trouver comme vous dites le salarié
idéal mais c'est le candidat idéal
plutôt mais c'est aussi donc pour moi le
candidat enfin le recrutement réussi
c'est le période d'essai qui est
concluante et que effectivement dans un
an en fait on retrouve toujours cette
personne et qu'elle soit aussi
satisfaite et que un employeur également
pour moi le recrutement c'est avant tout
une belle rencontre
[Musique]
cinq consultants d'accord régulier qui
interviennent sur des missions bien
spécifiques et j'ai aussi donc des
personnes aussi au bureau voilà on est
deux trois à peu près donc ça fait une
équipe de 8 à 10 personnes à peu près
avec des compétences exactement
spécifique des expertises bien bien
spécifiques mais qui se qui se
complètent alors
j'ai lu un peu dans ce que vous
produisez c'est vrai qu'il y a un
changement au fond de dans la façon
d'appréhender le rôle du salarié dans
une entreprise de nouvelles demandes on
voit bien qu'une évolution du marché du
travail qui a une évolution évidemment
on a vu avec le covid avec le
télétravail avec des façons de
travailler qui sont nouvelles avec des
demandes qui sont nouvelles de la part
des salariés peut-être avec des devants
qui sont nouvelles de la part des jeunes
générations aussi
et il y a beaucoup de choses c'est ça
j'explique comment comment trouver la
conscience de soi que trouver la
conscience de soi et d'une compétence
comment gérer ses émotions etc ça c'est
très important aussi
c'est vrai que c'est assez nouveau au
fond cette cette part un peu humaniste
de de la gestion des ressources humaines
de l'authenticité l'authenticité
il faut faire un peu de psychologie
d'être plutôt
à l'écoute et de oui psychologie en tout
cas
des évolutions comme vous le disez
effectivement il y a la digitalisation
qui est qui est là qui s'est accéléré
avec le le covid donc il y a aussi donc
la transition écologique qui est aussi
un fort en jeu il y a comme vous le
disiez aussi également le rapport au
travail et complètement différent donc
en fait le manager d'aujourd'hui doit
enfin n'est pas forcément
il devra pas forcément agir comme pour
en tant que manager de demain voilà et
donc c'est le sujet de l'une de mes
dedans des afterworks qui a lieu le 13
octobre
en effet le 13 octobre de 18h à 21h
ça passe à la galerie pela de Villebon
l'hôtel de bouillon c'est ça Versailles
avec deux invités principaux Maryse
Juranville qui est président d'esprit de
service France et un enseignant
je sais qui
et le thème c'est voyage au cœur du
management
façonner le manager de demain se décide
aujourd'hui c'est quoi le monde pourquoi
ça va changer beaucoup d'être manager
demain en fait on parlait là dedans
d'authenticité et c'est vrai que le
manager déjà doit se dire ce doit d'être
expert évidemment dans son domaine et il
doit être aussi à l'écoute de son équipe
et il va être encore de plus en plus
être proche de des besoins de son équipe
donc il devra effectivement accompagner
le développement personnel de ses
équipes c'est
d'être un leader entre guillemets étudie
éthique voilà
exactement donc pour moi voilà c'est ce
qu'on a on verra ça de plus en détail
Charles-Henri Bessard des Orres et Marie
j'ai envie de expliquons ça
ce sera un très bel événement sans être
c'est destiné à être récurrent quoi oui
exactement une fois par mois alors en
fait je souhaite que ces enfin je
souhaite le pour moi ces afterbox sont
[Musique]
ils sont vraiment pour les DRH et les
dirigeants
que ce sera souvent donc ça sera
essentiellement à Versailles c'est
ouvert vous invitez des gens
et donc réservation et généralement
ils peuvent vous contacter VIP
[Rires]
exactement
mais il faut que ça je veux que ça soit
convivial on sera entre 25 par exemple
et 30 personnes maximum faut que ce soit
vraiment une bulle d'oxygène pour ces
dirigeants et des RH qui viennent non
seulement écouter des intervenants de
qualité en management en ressources
humaines ou en sur les thématiques par
exemple de la prévention la prévention
ou santé du dirigeant parce que je veux
vraiment ce thème là me tient vraiment
tout particulièrement
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait
beaucoup de stress notamment chez les
CDRH
le stress tout le monde a du stress on a
tous du stress du bon comme du mauvais
donc là par exemple aujourd'hui j'ai dû
stress soigner
c'est du
bonheur
que les DRH sont stressés
tout poste on va dire qui demande des
exigences demande voilà c'est vrai que
c'est un poste
peut-être là-dessus mais où en effet
vous accompagner des salariés quand tout
va bien après il y a parfois des
décisions difficiles à prendre il y a
des parfois des licenciements parfois
des ruptures
de la manière dont c'est fait et dès
lors qu'on le fait avec respect et
bienveillance
votre société c'est donc rhumiste qui
est à Versailles et puis je rappelle le
13 octobre de 18h à 21h
c'est l'hôtel de bouillon c'est ça
j'ai su rentrer par hasard en juillet et
c'est une galerie d'art non mais j'ai
trouvé une galerie
donc je trouvais que c'était un mélange
enfin accepter c'était le bon endroit
avec cet espace conférence et dialogue
avec deux grands spécialistes et vous
évidemment bah merci beaucoup
[Musique]